say he stabbed himself in the neck and  isn't in critical condition two knives  were found at the scene  I see many and as vehicles gathering  nearby the rescue squad is setting up  blue tarp in which people injured abrete  to be treated oh just now I've seen  mainly Angeles's passing a rush into the  scene people injured ugly to be treated  inside the tarp even now I see school  bus parking nearby the scene according  to a man who said he spoke to a school  bus driver who were at the scene of the  attack said just when the elementary  school students were trying to get on  the bus men holding knives on both but  this morning in Tokyo all Americans  stand with the people of Japan and  grieved for the victims